the man is at a restaurant the waiters
like hey we have a great sea bass
tonight shut up the man says I would
like a juice glass with water a lemon
wedge and a match the waiters like what
okay you weirdo
the man pours the water onto the plate
he's like if you can get this water into
this glass without touching or moving
this here plate I will give you $100 tip
$100 riskiness that night the waiter
walked home $100 richer how'd he do it
you have to be some kind of sorcerer
some kind of magician or God if my
junior high science class taught me
anything I think like the lemon is for
the water after he drank he was gonna
drink the water anyone's lemon for the
water
I like 100% have to like this leverage
on fire anything
[ __ ] you which that's what I feel
alright yeah I kind of feel I just can't
figure out so I just need to keep the
air inside inside here so I'm guessing I
just think there's gotta be a way are
you supposed to light the match does the
fire help feel like it's just a surface
tension on the water did I get it right
Honda this is baloney so what's the
right answer well first the waiter put
the lemon in the center of the plate
then he lit the match and stuck it in
the lemon then he placed the glass
upside down over the lemon as the
matches flame used up the oxygen in the
glass it created a vacuum which sucked
in the water where the glass met the
plate so the waiter was able to get the
water into the glass without moving the
plate hey stop